everyone I'm Joel ashlar producer from
2k Australia hi everyone I'm James Lopez
producer at gearbox software and we're
here to show you a walkthrough of our e3
demo for Borderlands the pre-sequel hope
you enjoy it
alright so we're actually gonna be
playing through his Wilhelm during this
playthrough and we're selecting his
action skill now which is his ability to
spawn these two drones wolf and saint
wolf is an attacking drone while st. is
more of a buffing region drone we're
gonna go down the cyber commando skill
tree this one's really cool cuz if fans
remember will home from Borderlands 2 he
was just a giant loaded with a human
head on top but in this game it's his
origin story and he starts out just as a
man but you have the ability by going
down this skill tree to start turning
into that giant robot that he was in
Borderlands 2 by selecting the power
fist skill here and you'll see that
actually replaced his arm with this
robotic one this one's really cool
because it'll deal extra melee damage
and you can actually attack enemies from
further away and if you look at the
shock absorbers one which replaces his
leg with a robotic leg this allows you
to shoot and reload while you're
sprinting which can come in really handy
the media slam is also really useful
because the butt stomp or ground pound
or slam or whatever we're calling it
today is really really powerful oh boy
length per sequel when you're playing in
low gravity you're able to do this huge
amount of damage when you slam down to
the ground and that's about all the
skill punch we can use right now but
we're pretty close to leveling up again
so what we do we're gonna show you the
vengeance cannon which is Wilhelm's
capstone skill and set the size of
commando tree and we have a look here we
actually just shot an air geyser and
we're neither short they shoot out this
oxygen which replenishes Europe
I was keeps but it also repels you up in
the air and the higher you get and the
more damage from your buck stops so if
you hold that Crouch button you slam
down the ground you that deal this huge
amount of damage to enemy on the ground
yeah guys are a great way to do a slam
immediately instead of having to kinda
like prime yourself board you can hop on
one of those and just immediately move
off and slam someone to oblivion if you
want to here's another example of how
the levels are flown by low gravity for
lengthy procedure you're able to do
these massive leaps and bounds and
really you have normal freedom as a
player to the scope of travel
increased so much and we're able to use
the adverse by venting some auction
you're actually able to go even further
by propelling yourself forward or even
fire
yeah and it's cool but we have these
abilities they obviously come with some
cost of them the oxygen meter well we
get plenty of ways for you to get that
oxygen vacuum we've got oxygen canisters
have dropped when when you feel enemies
we have the air geysers we have up we
have other like cracks in the ground and
air can come out up they won't give you
that jump but they won't give you back
your option they'll also have oxygen
generators and even like certain Oz kiss
will allow you to create an oxygen
bubble whenever you do a slam attack
these enemies that were fighting in the
movie the Krakens there's some ones are
moonbeasts they're essentially these
these new rock monsters but because this
is water lands they absorb elemental
attributes as well and these ones have
been absorbed higher energy they have a
lot of liquid meat hanging around this
area of Elvis and they've kind of
inherited those abilities and that kind
of doing prior damage towards you um but
you have the ability to kill them but
what's really interesting about these
guys is when you kill them they actually
shatter into two smaller crackers yeah
so you want to start off one on one an
FTL you've got a pretty even Feist but
as they break into smaller groups and
become more numerous you might have a
really big fight on your hand all right
why don't we try and show the wolf
insane to you
all right so will him just deployed
whooping seen those are his two drones
wolf is going to go out and cause me
some trouble Saints gonna stay fairly
close by to replenish Wilhelm shields as
a favor drop now our well home player is
pretty thorough so yeah might need to
get a little more challenging fight form
you can see these beautiful ice
particles within you cryo element that
we're going to again you can freeze and
shatter any enemy and depending on which
angle you attack these guys from they're
actually gonna float off into low
gravity in that direction if you could
you slam down any while they're frozen
you actually gonna split them in half
and watch their ice chunks float off
yeah that's really cool because of the
way that they shadow it's always kind of
customized to like whichever way you hit
them so it never really gets all it's
always different each time it's really
fun now our current objective in this
particular level is to redirect some
liquid methane we need to get to the
Drakensberg which is this derelict dial
ship where we've been informed as a
military either we can use jack bones to
build up this robot army he needs this
military AI to use it so we're currently
trying to redirect as me thing to cool
off a lava river boss now we were just
fighting the dragon but over here you
can actually see that some of the scabs
are actually writing this which is
pitting of which no you got to watch out
for because you have two enemies
attacking you and whenever you kill one
of these crying riders you might get a
couple of old dragon writers coming up
you see woolen on was also using these
jumpers so along with the oxygen guys is
we have these doll
jump pads with your place read the
levels in some of these should you
straight up into the air and other one's
kind of propelling really far forward
again if you manage to change some of
these to get really really high into a
slam which doesn't mess amount of damage
look at some of these guys you'll see
that some of these scabs have the sort
of orange bubble over their head that's
their oxygen bubble that means that if
you crack that bubble then they're going
to take oxygen damage because they're
not able breathe that was a really cool
way cuz you can kind of do a hit and run
you don't have to worry about this way
without finishing them off if you're
taking too much heat you can just wait
for them to succeed but some of these
guys also have shields and air bubbles
in todaya they're a little more of a
stronger fight have to watch out they're
more dangerous
so you can see that's an example one of
the dog jump pets which shoots really
far forward and here we have some of the
that's all jet fighters and that they're
going to fly around and try and do a
huge amount energy and Wilhelm is doing
pretty well yeah that's a spot on it
that's really good oh no but you fell
off the side that's ok because we've got
plenty of jump pads we have a lot more
verticality and boarding lives now the
waiver good so there's it's not
necessarily any one way to get this
objective really all I has to do is just
find out either a jump out of our way to
jump from from platform to pot yeah
something really great about the the low
oxygen it allows you to traverse there's
no
really quickly so you because you can
make these messy leaps and bounds and
you have these jump cuts you're able to
get run into the meth very very fast and
really get an edge on enemies all right
now it looks like we just leveled up so
we're going to go and put that skill
point and vengeance cannon that's really
interesting because you if you take a
certain amount of damage
Wilhelm responds with the Vengeance
cannon and you can do a great amount of
damage within a pretty generous in a
period of time you have about 30 seconds
of ACMA of action on coming really
really powerful when you're under the
pump yeah so you can see now with that
we're actually redirecting this look at
my veins
you know to go over and try and freeze
this lava lake
all right so once this pipe connects we
actually have another route on how we
can get to the next objective you could
just go down to the ground if you wanted
to but because of the verticality and
pre-sequel we can actually continue
along this path here all I have to do is
have the option to make the jump and
then you can actually run along this
pipe here so there's plenty of ways to
explore this map and get pretty much
anywhere you need to get yeah it's
really it's really cool as well a little
design has a built-in map so especially
when you're playing co-op you can have
each play they can approach each of
these sites from different angles so we
could have taken that pipe all the way
along while McLean and went down by the
ground and went over to the by the jump
pack that people that are especially
fond of sniping should keep an eye out
for these kind of opportunities because
you get a superior angle from which you
can snipe off those oxygen bubbles or
distance punch of damage in general yeah
absolutely we're going to continue along
this way and Athena's going to continue
on the ground and they're both getting
that she's going to jump cross this
chasm here we're gonna go on to the next
big fight yeah we should be able to
ambush these guys by taking them from
two different angles once Wilhelm you
know finds a way to jump over this there
we go alright so this way here we've got
some jetpacks calves we also have some
guys that on foot they actually see a
scab that if you know just kill just
flying off in the distance it'll go on
like that for quite some time yeah if he
still has any luck lifting him he's sick
getting pretty painful
oh yeah
oh no fins down hey we'll know once you
go ahead and revive we're using the
oxygen yeah so you kind of these full
the kind of technical decisions you can
revive your down players faster with
oxygen then if you just you know do the
normal way but that obviously comes at a
class but you know sometimes it's really
good to get them in this fight faster
you can see we have these jetpacks
cancer all the enemies on Elpis can take
advantage of the low gravity just as
much as you can so if you're getting
protection behind color they can
actually jump up and stomp on you and
invalidate you'll come just like and
then we really want to describe
basically your throughout every single
feature movie it's they're pretty
awesome but stuntman about solid your
some of our vending machines were kind
of teasing as we run by them but you can
see more about the literally we're
coming in the processing point now this
is actually where you just directed the
liquid methane to and it's really
important to do this because we're going
to use it to freeze a lava river sipping
form of Natural Bridge they cross over
to the dragons market in the next round
now this has a lot of enemies in we're
definitely gonna bring out multi scenes
yeah
carnies those jump and did a lot
advantage of the playability stomp down
he just shot that Scout into that
problem because of his uh because of the
austerity tax they're really cool
because each oz kit have a variety of
you can't own some of them will do you
know your basic option in extension but
some also add elemental attacks some
will create oxygen bubbles when we do a
slam there's a lot of layers to convince
you I feel inclined to uh centers here
here elevated and being that and
optionally put stuff obviously these
sort of varieties are really important
to us whenever we added the ice
elemental this also is represented
across all gear items and you know
you've added a shield that into need
unless you guys need guns and we also
have lasers laser support all the
elemental so we we've added even more
Brazilians come here yeah you can see
right here we have a nice laser so we're
able to shoot this beam is kind of
freeze right and then we can cut stump
and hopefully shutter this guy getting
close really oh wow you get the more
damage you're going to be
great clothes oh maybe a mistake a
killer that's okay though it's always
next time
so it looks like we cleared out the
enemies here let's try and get that
anything on the lava river sir I've got
my babies borderlines nurse oh he always
have to leave that's right let's take
all his ninja
that is the 10 year old boy who tried to
help us you're fired
you can see the directions that I got
there in the distance so that's our
object we want to get to this crashed
doll ship let's get this military AI
once we get that military I say I Jack
can put in some loaders what's happened
to this point had been useless you know
there's just construction box basically
but once you put the AI and then we'll
be able to weaponize the loaders and
reclaim Helios which is the moonshot
facility
success let's make it one more lens beam
without a bunch of big baddie snap fun
if they just get bigger and bigger I
realize that he's an ice dragon but he
also has lava inside of them yeah I see
that all the time that makes sense
all right guys and that's that's our e3
demo we hope you enjoyed seeing it
please stay tuned for more pre sequel
news